ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct sur notre antenne la
séance de questions cribles thématiques
elle est consacrée aujourd'hui au grand
paris c'est maurice leroy ministre de la
ville qui vient répondre aux questions
des sénateurs
je vous rappelle le principe de ces
questions cribles le ministre à deux
minutes pour répondre aux questions d'un
sénateur qui dispose à son tour d'une
minute pour lui répondre
alors le grand paris a le projet de loi
a été voté par le parlement il ya à peu
près dix mois après un ultime vote du
sénat
à l'époque les sénateurs de l'opposition
avaient voté contre ce texte qu'il juge
et recentralisateur et autoritaire le
grand paris c'est avant tout la
construction d'une double boucle d'un
métro automatique autour de paris
l'objectif de ce métro qui portera le
nom de grand paris express car c'est à
la fois une synthèse du projet du
gouvernement de grand paris et du projet
porté par la région ile de france
arc express son objectif sera donc de
mieux desservir la banlieue les
aéroports mais également d'améliorer et
de désengorger les lignes de métro et de
rer existantes pour cela à 32 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2025 vont être développe
des blocs est à la fois cet
investissement sera supporté par les
collectivités locales mais aussi par
l'état et par l'emprunt la question du
fait non du financement va être au coeur
des débats cet après midi car cela
inquiète les élus franciliens notamment
les sénateurs franciliens parmi les
autres sujets d'inquiétude et sur
lesquels maurice leroy aura à répondre
cet après midi aux sénateurs il s'agit
de la desserte du plateau de saclay
c'est laurent béteille sénateur ump de
l'essonne qui va interpeller un maurice
leroy sur cette question car pour lui si
l'on souhaite que saclay puisse
rivaliser avec les autres pôles
scientifiques au niveau européen il faut
absolument que saclay soit relié à paris
moins de 30 minutes et à roissy en moins
de 50 minutes
autre thème abordé à cette fois-ci par
les sénatrice socialiste catherine tasca
et nicole bricq il s'agit du stif le
syndicat des transports d'île de france
comment va-t-il être intégrée au grand
paris la réponse tout de suite
avec ces questions cribles à la
proposition de loi sur le sdrif dont
nous discuterons demain constituera le
premier acte fondateur du protocole
celui qui donnera le ton des relations
est à région dans les mois à venir
d'autres engagements de vont être
concrétisés au plus vite il faudra
d'abord définir les tracés la société du
grand paris devra tirer les leçons des
débats publics en proposant un tracé
précis le protocole entérine l'objectif
d'une desserte fine des territoires au
profit du plus grand nombre
l'accord porte une bien meilleure
desserte que l'ancien grand 8 mai des
gars reste optionnel et les demandes des
élus locaux
relayé par la région n'ont pas toutes
été prises en compte pour le moment
s'agissant des financements plusieurs
engagements de l'état reste à graver
dans le marbre
que pouvez-vous nous en dire s'agissant
enfin du partage de la maîtrise
d'ouvragé
point particulièrement important pour
réaliser dans les meilleurs délais le
plan de mobilisation et le réseau grand
paris
vous avez annoncé que la sgp passerait
une convention de coordination technique
et financière avec le stif pour
l'associer au projet de rocade une
convention suffira-t-elle
la volonté affichée par le protocole de
trouver les moyens d'un partage de la
maîtrise d'ouvragé pose deux questions
la première concernant le métro
automatique le président du conseil
régional a fait part de sa volonté que
le stif soit maître d'ouvragé de la
ligne 14 et d'un des tronçons de la
future rocade
deuxième question la nécessité de
sécuriser
juridiquement le rôle du stif en tant
qu'autorité organisatrice des transports
la loi grand paris fait l'impasse sur
les enjeux d'exploitation du réseau
futur et sur les problématiques
d'interconnexion et de correspondances
avec le réseau existant
c'est au stif que revient la
responsabilité d'assurer la cohérence du
futur réseau et la charge d'exploiter le
futur métro le protocole état région
prévoit que le cadre juridique de ce
partage soit élaboré au cours du premier
semestre 2011
où en est on la réussite de ce projet de
transport est décisive pour les
franciliens et le développement de la
région ile de france
à chaque collègue pour la réponse
monsieur maurice leroy ministre de la
ville
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre catherine tasca je veux
réaffirmer solennellement devant la
haute assemblée que le rôle du syndicat
des transports d'ile-de-france comme
autorités organisatrices de transports
en ile-de-france n'est pas remis en
cause et ne sera pas remis en cause je
lui dis devant votre commission
allocations des affaires économiques à
l'occasion de l'examen de la proposition
de loi et je le redis donc sur votre
interpellation très clairement
vous le savez la long la loi du 3 juin
2010 à laquelle vous avez fait référence
dans votre intervention ne remet pas en
cause le rôle du syndicat des transports
d'île de france
mais il semble nécessaire et je le fais
volontiers de clarifier ce sujet à
l'aune du projet de métro automatique en
rocade dont l'oncle l'ampleur inédite en
ile de france aura un impact indéniable
sur la cohérence et l'exploitation
future du système de transport
francilien
c'est un engagement vous avez eu raison
de le rappeler madame la ministre de
l'accord du 26 janvier qui au-delà d'une
vision partagée sur le tracé réaffirme
souci d'une association pleine et
entière du stif dans la réalisation de
la rocade pour la société du grand paris
et je confirme comme je lé fais en
commission
tout à fait solennellement de nouveau
que effectivement nous allons mettre en
oeuvre cet accord et par conséquent je
suis tout à fait disposé à prendre
toutes les mesures pour ce pour que le
prolongement de la ligne 14 entre
saint-lazare et saint-ouen soit
effectivement confié au syndicat des
transports d'ile-de-france donc vous le
voyez nous respectant complètement
l'accord signé entre l'état et le
président de la région ile de france
jean paul huchon ne gouvernement donc y
travaillent et en association avec le
conseil régional d'île de france
bien entendu je suis prêt à examiner
toutes les voies conventionnelle et
réglementaires pour concrétiser cette
association le plus vite possible mais
sans que nous ayons à modifier
effectivement la loi du 3 juin 2010 une
modification du code des transports
pourra être étudiée si les moyens
conventionnels ne donnent pas les
résultats espérés dans l'ouest un
engagement clair que je donne au nom de
l'état et du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci de votre question
ministre pour la réplique la parole est
à mme allain briques
oui monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivrons ce dialogue et à propos de
la maîtrise d'ouvragé demain à
l'occasion de la discussion notre
proposition de loi mais je vois qu'on
avance quand même petit à petit puisque
maintenant vous évoquez une convention
ce que vous avez déjà fait en commission
et la voie réglementaire bon nous il
nous semble que la meilleure voie
c'était la voie législative parce que
quand je rentre je relis le protocole
il était inscrit dans le marbre que le
cadre juridique de ce partage sera
élaboré au cours du premier semestre
donc la voie législative et est quand
même la meilleure maintenant vous nous
dites si la convention ne marchait pas
on ne sait pas quelle échéance
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que le conseil
de surveillance de la sgp va déterminer
pour ce qui concerne le métro est
automatique le nom de gare et l'état y
est majoritaire vous connaissez les
débats que nous avons eus l'année passée
donc votre réponse pour l'instant nous
laisse encore sur notre faim il ya un
principe en maîtrise d'ouvragé
quand on paye on partage la maîtrise d
ouvrage
merci mme asha collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur bernard véra pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
des sénateurs du parti de gauche
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le débat public sur le grand
paris a mobilisé de nombreux franciliens
et à révéler leurs fortes attentes en
matière de logement d'aménagement et de
transport avant même la publication du
rapport de la commission nationale du
débat public
l'état et la région ont signé le 26
janvier dernier un protocole d'accord
permettant la mise en oeuvre du projet
des transports nouvellement intitulé
grand paris express
cependant même réviser ce projet pour la
région capitale conserve son orientation
libérale fondée sur la compétition entre
les territoires
l'organisation pour le de compétitivité
et d'excellence aggravera encore
davantage les inégalités territoriales
enfin la reprise en main par l'état de
l'aménagement francilien n'est nullement
remise en cause et le financement du
schéma de transports restent imprécis et
surtout un certain sur un total de 32,4
milliards d'euros d'ici à 2025 11,9
milliards seront consacrés au plan de
mobilisation des transports tandis que
le financement de grand paris express
s'élèvera à 25 milliards dont seules
10,5 sont actuellement garantie ainsi
tout laisse à penser que les
collectivités
et locales et les usagers seront mis à
contribution notamment par une hausse
des tarifs de transport de plus la
pression foncière accrue va repousser
toujours plus loin de la capitale
les populations les plus modestes votre
projet de grand paris est organisé
autour de pôles de compétitivité reliés
par un métro automatique alors que
l'urgence est au maillage des
territoires par le développement de
transports de proximité
certes le nombre de gares a sensiblement
augmenté permettant de favoriser le
transport de banlieue à banlieue
toutefois le nouveau schéma de transport
n'améliore pas la desserte de plusieurs
pans du territoire francilien
essentiellement en grande couronne et
dans les zones plutôt rural il est donc
regrettable que la seule vision que l'on
nous propose soit à long terme celle
d'un réseau unique conférer des
transports en attendant des pans entiers
de territoire sont oubliés au détriment
d'un développement cohérent et solidaire
de la région ile de france
l'urgence est au renforcement et au
déploiement de transport de proximité
tram train tramway ligne de bus en site
propre
alors monsieur le ministre quelle mesure
entendez-vous prendre afin de favoriser
le développement des transports de
proximité afin de réduire les inégalités
de territoire en rééquilibrant l'offre
de transport et afin d'améliorer les
déplacements des populations et des
salariés enrichiront ministre de la
ville merci madame la présidente
monsieur bernard véra bon je vais pas
rentrer dans le débat surtout en deux
minutes de réponse sur vision libérale
ou pas libérale du projet du grand paris
on prolongera dans d'autres débats si
vous le souhaitez je suis à votre
disposition pour cela je vous invite
simplement vous rapprocher du président
christian favier président du conseil
général du val de marne et vous lui
demanderez s'ils pensent que le travail
que nous avons fait ensemble pour
améliorer les conditions de transport
des franciliens
vous demanderez au président claude
bartolone si le travail que nous avons
fait ensemble pour contribuer à
l'amélioration quotidienne et transport
des franciliens étaient une vision
libérale et vous demandez aux
président huchon si il a signé un accord
libéral alors vous m'interrogez par
ailleurs sur les financements les
financements grâce d'ailleurs au budget
voté par la majorité sénatoriale ici
même grâce à votre rapporteur général du
budget grâce à l'excellent travail fait
par le rapporteur général du budget
gilles carez à l'assemblée nationale les
moyens financiers sont au rendez vous et
vous devriez monsieur verra vous en
féliciter parce que grâce au plan de
mobilisation notamment ma collègue
nathalie kosciusko morizet va pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre dès cette année 500
millions d'euros des crédits du plan de
mobilisation en lien avec la région
ile-de-france pour déjà moderniser les
lignes c et d du rer
et ça c'est l'amélioration quotidienne
des transports c'est pas du discours
c'est pas un cours sur schumpeter et de
libéralisme ce serait passionnant mais
enfin voilà ça c'est du concret pour les
franciliens et franchement j'avoue ma
surprise à votre intervention parce que
franchement le grand paris c'est une
vision qu'a eus le président de la
république on doit tous s'en réjouir
pour l'avenir pour l'avenir de l'île de
france pour la région capitale et on
devrait tous en fait s'est félicité
franchement sur tous les bancs sans
esprit partisan
parce que c'est un projet qui dépasse le
temps politique et le temps médiatique
et je suis heureux de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre ce projet avec la région ile de
france
effectivement merci monsieur bernard
véra pour la réplique minutes
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
me j'ai bien
écoutez votre votre réponse je continue
de penser que la mise en oeuvre de la
loi sur le grand paris met en péril la
cohérence territoriale au niveau
régional et nous sommes pour notre part
convaincu que le concept de pôle de
compétitivité concentrant toutes les
richesses et aspirant l'essentiel des
financements publics va contribuer
également à assécher les autres
territoires
enfin le schéma de transport moi je vous
parle en tant que parlementaire
essonniens je ne vous parle pas en tant
que parlementaires des départements que
vous avez cités enfin le schéma de
transport pose un double problème il est
injuste dans son financement pour les
collectivités territoriales qui portent
gravement atteinte à la démocratie
locale
en effet les communes qui ne signeront
pas de contrat développement territorial
perdront toute maîtrise de l'aménagement
dans un périmètre de 400 m autour de
leur quart alors que dans le même temps
elles participeront au financement du
réseau
en conclusion monsieur mini j'aurais
vous dire que cette loi sur le grand
paris ne fera qu'accentuer les
inégalités territoriales comme le fera
d'ailleurs à l'échelle nationale la loi
de réforme des collectivités
territoriales merci la parole est
maintenant à monsieur yves pozzo di
borgo pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
mes chers collègues à partir de 1910
l'éclatement des universités la
délocalisation des pôles universitaires
à marne la vallée evry et palaiseau n'a
pas eu d'impact positif en termes
d'attractivité parisienne en partie à
cause des transports et les services
rimmel et très mal l'ensemble de ses
pôles le pôle scientifique de saclay ne
pourront être actif et vous l'avez
rappelé dans le protocole d'accord du 26
janvier que s'il est relié à paris à
moins de 30 minutes marié réticences du
conseil régional sur un desserte par le
métro automatique pourraient avoir
l'assurance monsieur le ministre au
gouvernement mais atteindra fermement sa
position de desserte du plateau de
saclay par le métro deuxième question il
semblerait que le gouvernement veuille
finances
les opérations sur le plateau de saclay
par la vente des établissements
transféré à saclay notamment l'école des
mines d'établissements parisiens pardon
l'école des mines de paris la maison des
sciences de l'homme à paris l'école
nationale supérieure des
télécommunications à paris et l'institut
agronomique aussi à paris vous c'est
bien monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui
que sainte anne en black nick vie la
cité parisienne sont devenus des marques
dont l'attractivité vient aussi dure
situation géographique au coeur de la
cité alors nous déshabillons paris pour
saclay nous pouvons l'accepter mais si
la raison pour laquelle nous vous
demandons et nous souhaitons avec
plusieurs universités parisiennes avec
la ville de paris et l'opposition
parisienne dont je fais partie que
justement nous puissions maintenir
d'assez bâtiment une activité
universitaire et de recherche
complémentaire à celle de saclay
pouvez-vous me garantir monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement ne s'opposera
pas de tel projet
si monsieur le ministre maurice leroy
ministre de la ville
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur yves pozzo di borgo
je vais vous répondre de la façon la
plus claire possible que dans le
protocole entre l'état et la région ile
de france
nous assurons effectivement une desserte
de massy saclay saint quentin en
yvelines et versailles par un métro
automatique qui va effectivement
respecter la zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière et
comme vous l'avez très bien dit cela
permettra et c'est indispensable de
relier le pôle scientifique au centre de
la capitale en 30 minutes le
développement du plateau de saclay vous
le savez est une condition essentielle
du renforcement de l'attractivité de
notre région capitale et je vous c'est
particulièrement sensible à cet aspect
comme élu parisien
les investissements du plan campus
et du grand emprunt porté par valérie
pécresse et rené ricol sont les éléments
déclencheurs d'un projet d'aménagement
et de développement
et en ce qui concerne l'immobilier
universitaire parisien sur lequel vous
m'interpeller les mouvements actuels et
les nouvelles opérations à paris rive
gauche sur le campus condorcet ou plus
largement dans le cadre du schéma
directeur
fruit du travail de bernard larrouturou
dont une occasion de dynamiser de
fortifier les implantations
universitaire et d'enseignement
supérieur du coeur de la métropole
ainsi c'est bien au total un projet de
développement conjoint de saclay et de
l'enseignement supérieur du coeur de la
capitale qui est visé les premiers
résultats des opérations
d'investissements d'avenir en attestent
et donc je tiens vraiment à vous
rassurer sur ces questions s'agit pas du
tout de déshabiller les universités
parisiennes au profit de saclay il
s'agit de conforter l'attractivité de la
région capitale en ayant effectivement
un pôle de recherche et développement
fort et universités fort sur le plateau
sacrées heures pas un projet nouveau
saint projet dont on parle depuis et le
général de gaulle et qui ne s'était
jamais fait donc il est vraiment temps
de le faire voilà si pour la réplique
madame catherine morin desailly madame
la présidente je voulais souligner
également que l'ambition du grand paris
c'est aussi de relier la capitale à sa
façade maritime est de faire du havre le
grand port de paris mais ne ferait pas
oublier rement le port de rouen dans
cette affaire dont les résultats sont
parmi les meilleures des grands ports
maritimes cette année la réussite du
projet du grand paris ne peut se
concevoir comme je les dis monsieur le
ministre à vos prédécesseurs que
concomitamment à une autre ambition un
courte ont acquis et celle du territoire
normand le grand paris ne
saurait se résumer à un corridor qui
acheminerait les marchandises et les
savoirs vers la mer autour de l'axé
seine comme le comité du port l'a
démontré à travers les scénarii
envisagés pour la nouvelle ligne paris
normandie voulue par le président de la
république c'est bien entendu à
l'échelle transrégionale qui nous faudra
travailler
celle de l'île de france et des deux
normandie c'est aussi à cette échelle
que devra se concevoir une politique
d'aménagement du territoire que suppose
le grand paris prenant en compte le
potentiel de notre région potentiel de
développement industriel logistique
universitaires économiques et ceci dans
le respect des grands équilibres
environnementaux et démographique
si la parole est maintenant à madame
françoise laborde pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je ne reviendrai pas sur les
raisons qui m'ont poussé tout comme la
majorité des membres du groupe rdse a
voté contre la loi 2010 sur le grand
paris
la principale d'entre elles étant
l'instrumentalisation du débat des fins
politiciennes par le président de la
république que de temps perdu depuis le
schéma directeur régional d'île de
france de 2008
trois ministres une loi et une
commission nationale pour le débat
public plus tard force est de constater
que la principale avancée pour le grand
paris et d'avoir considérablement
retardé les travaux programmés par la
région ile de france
pour moi l'objectif fondamental du grand
paris est d'améliorer les conditions de
vie des habitants et le lien social
entre les populations
c'est pourquoi si j'en avais le temps
monsieur le ministre je vous demanderai
comment vous comptez éviter de
reproduire sous une autre forme
les erreurs d'urbanisme commises dans
les années 70 au seul bénéfice des
promoteurs immobiliers je vous
demanderais aussi de réintroduire des
services publics de proximité afin de
désenclaver les quartiers sensibles et
les rendre attractifs enfin je pourrais
vous demander que soient équitablement
répartis l'effort de financement afin
d'éviter que les tarifs ou la fiscalité
locale des ménages franciliens ne
subissent une hausse exponentielle
mais aujourd'hui j'attends que vous
preniez des engagements pour qu'un
effort supplémentaire soit consacrée au
volet intermodalité d'une part entre les
réseaux
de transport francilien et d'autre part
en ce qui concerne leur interconnexion
avec les grandes villes nationales de
train pour que vive la province le
réseau de transport est d'abord un
ciment social et pas seulement une
passerelle entre les bassins d'emploi
c'est à ce prix à ce prix seulement que
le projet grand paris apportera une
valeur ajoutée à la région et luttera
contre les inégalités sociales
monsieur le ministre la commission
nationale du débat public en son rapport
jeudi
et j'ose espérer que les questions que
nous soulevons aujourd'hui auront leur
place dans le schéma directeur
les bonnes intentions ne suffisent pas
les franciliens attendent des actes je
vous remercie
merci monsieur maurice leroy ministre de
la ville
merci la présidente madame la sénatrice
françoise laborde avoir je me réjouis qu
une sénatrice de haute-garonne prennent
part au débat sur le grand paris et je
mens je m'en réjouis et je m'en réjouis
j'allais le dire monsieur sueur mais
vous ne savez pas ce que je veux dire
surprendre m'en réjouir de me féliciter
alors ne vous fâchez pas c'est tout la
main suis je m'en réjouis
suis moi même élu d'un département qui
n'est pas franciliens et donc c'est pas
moi qui vais faire ce procès donc ne
prenez pas à à contre courant alors je
me réjouis c'est justement qu'il n'y ait
pas que des élus franciliens donc voila
voila voyez plutôt applaudir voilà donc
j'ai et justement si vous ne m'aviez pas
interrompu est ce ma vie' laisser aller
au bout de mon propos je vous aurais dit
je m'en réjouis vraiment parce que le
grand paris n'est pas qu'une affaire de
parisiens ou de franciliens voilà voyez
c'est mieux de laisser aller au bout des
phrases et donc effectivement ça n'est
pas une affaire que de parisiens et de
franciliens voilà et si je ne suis pas
d'accord sur le reste du contenu ça ne
vous surprendra pas de votre
intervention voilà madame où il ya eu
des erreurs effectivement des urbanistes
d'ailleurs même quand on n'est pas calée
sur les questions de politique de la
ville
on se plante jamais en visitant une cité
de transit qui devait être du transit
mais qui a duré pendant des années et en
général quand on demande au maire quelle
que soit sa sensibilité politique on se
plante jamais en dix ans ce ne serait
pas par hasard un grand prix de rome qui
a fait cette magnifique cité n'est ce
pas et en général
succès garanti ce sont à chaque fois des
grand prix de rome alors c'est pas moi
qui vous diraient le contraire
malheureusement c'est comme ça voilà
puis je parlerai pas de de l'idéologie
qui sous tendait à l'époque ces grandes
barres qui devra mener la grande vie
voilà merveilleuse et on sait comment
tout cela s'est traduit madame la
sénatrice
si nous faisons dans la loi du grand
paris
les contrats de développement
territoriaux c'est précisément pour
éviter de reproduire ses erreurs et donc
ces contrats de développement
territoriaux et se font parfaite
harmonie concertation entre les services
de l'état et les collectivités
territoriales concernées
donc c'est un véritable partenariat qui
s'engagent pour éviter précisément de
reproduire ce type d'erreur est donc
réjouissons-nous là aussi de toute
sensibilité qu'on se dote d'outils
d'urbanisme qui permettent d'éviter ces
nouvelles erreurs
quant au schéma directeur régional
d'ile-de-france donc dont vous avez
parlé je me réjouis que demain nous nous
retrouvions ensemble à l'initiative du
groupe socialiste et de madame briques
mais avec un excellent travail fait par
dominique braille votre rapporteur
l'ensemble de la majorité sénatoriale
pour tous ensemble libérez effectivement
les projets qui sont actuellement
bloqués dans le sdrif
c'est un engagement que j'avais pris
avec le président huchon
j'obtiens cet engagement et nous le
tenons ensemble avec la représentation
nationale donc réjouissons-nous
effectivement de cela et donc tirons les
leçons de toutes ces espèces
quant au financement madame la cfs il
est parfaitement équilibré
dix milliards d'euros de l'état ça me
permet de reprendre aussi monsieur
bernard véra et 11 milliards des
collectivités territoriales donc
franchement c'est un financement
équilibré et et qui permettra d'éviter
ce que vous craignez vous avez raison et
dans votre rôle de m'interpeller le sans
solliciter excessivement le contribuable
donc je pense que vous devriez être
plutôt assurée par cette réponse s'il
ministre mais mme laborde pour la
réplique
merci madame la présidente monsieur 2010
je ne demande qu'à vous faire confiance
et donc je vais je vais le faire nous
allons suivre dont acte avec les
franciliens et les parisiens je veux
quand même souligné que bon le facteur
temps est important parce qu'elle
développement à long terme mais il ya
aussi tout ce qui ce fait vous qui ne se
fait pas encore à court terme et j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est le printemps et
je voudrais que le schéma soit le soleil
etc autour de chaque gare nous ayons des
connexions importante nombreuses et
rapidement pour que tous les franciliens
et parisiens puissent se déplacer sur
merci merci la parole est maintenant
monsieur laurent béteille pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire merci
au président seul ministre de questions
la première c'est sur la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière dans le périmètre de l'oin du
plateau de saclay j'avais déposé un
amendement lors de l'examen du texte
devant notre assemblée pour préciser que
la zone de protection devrait comporter
obligatoirement au moins 2300 hectares
de terres consacrées aux activités
agricoles est située sur la petite
région du plateau de saclay à l'oral à
l'heure actuelle nous attendons toujours
le décret d'application définissant les
conditions d'application de l'article 21
de la loi et ceci bien que le calendrier
soit dépassé donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je tenais monsieur le ministre
a réitéré l' extrême importance que nous
attachons à cette protection de façon à
ce qu'elles soient fixées vraiment dans
les meilleurs délais puisque ça
conditionne tout le reste finalement
l'emplacement du reste et
ce soit effectivement d'un seul tenant
et sur le plateau lui-même comme ç'avait
été convenu la deuxième question elle
porte sur l'accord entre la région et
l'état sur le grand paris et je suis de
ceux qui se félicite de cet accord est
également des projets qui permettront de
faire des liaisons de banlieue à
banlieue qui sont vraiment très attendu
mais pour autant il ya le problème des
rer existant sur lequel je voulais
attirer l'attention du ministre parce
que sur cette somme il y à 2010 sur la
somme convenue il ya deux millions de
milliards 3 pour les rer 1 milliard 3
qui concerne le remplacement des rames
du rer à sauf erreur de ma part
220 millions d'euros pour b plus et
seulement 500 millions d'euros pour le
erreur c est 500 millions d'euros
polaire rer d et je crains que ces
sommes très franchement soit
insuffisante pour permettre de faire
face à la vétusté et encore plus au
problème l'accroissement du trafic
auquel nous serons forcément confrontés
et en particulier il sera nécessaire de
doubler un jour le châtelet le tunnel
entre châtelet et gare du nord
et pour ceux que cette opération il n'y
a pas de financement
il ya simplement indiqué pour mémoire ce
qui effectivement permet pas de financer
grand chose donc monsieur le ministre qu
en est il est ce qu'on va aller vers
cette porte cette nécessité qu'est le
doublement du tunnel
si monsieur leroy ministre de la ville
merci madame la présidente monsieur
sénateurs laurent béteille
je sais que vous suivez ces questions
personnellement voilà particulièrement
bien et je vous en remercier vous
m'interpeller sur la question de la zone
des 2300 hectares d'espacés agricoles
naturels forestiers qui doivent être
identifiés effectivement est préservée
dans le cadre du projet de l'opération
d'intérêt national de paris saclay
l'établissement public de paris-saclay
finalise à l'heure actuelle
une étude avec la société d'aménagement
foncier et d'établissement rural pour
délimiter précisément ses 2300 hectares
ces travaux donneront lieu prochainement
à la publication du décret d'application
auquel vous faites référence sans doute
dès cet automne je veux être clair dans
ma réponse
s'il paraît impossible d'éviter des
enclaves qui existe déjà un principe de
continuité sera bien entendu et dans la
mesure du possible privilégier pour
assurer une bonne gestion du patrimoine
agricole naturel et forestiers du
plateau cela se fera en cohérence avec
un projet d'aménagement qui fait la part
belle aux principes de compacité en
valorisant le paysage notamment dans la
frange sud du plateau
sur la question des transports monsieur
le sénateur il convient de saluer
l'effort sans précédent de modernisation
des rer sur lesquels lequel la région
les départements et l'état se sont
entendues alors bon je connais la thèse
elle existe j'ai aussi été interpellé à
l'assemblée nationale par vos collègues
parlementaires peut toujours considérer
que 500 millions sur le rer c est 500
millions sur leur r d c'est pas
suffisant mais enfin accordez moi que vu
l'état de nos finances publiques
objectivement ça va être quand même
considérable savoir se mettre en oeuvre
rapidement et je crois que c'est
effectivement important je ne rappelle
pas le volet de 20 milliards et demi
consacrée au réseau du grand paris
express qui soulagera fortement la
partie centrale du réseau actuel rer
compris et vous avez raison de dire
aujourd'hui asphyxiée
je me penche donc à votre invitation sur
les mesures complémentaires mais
immédiate de modernisation des lignes
rer qui sont du ressort du syndicat des
transports d'ile-de-france comme vous le
savez à travers leur vision partagée
responsable au vu des enjeux de l'état
des finances publiques
l'état et la région décidé d'investir
massivement dans la modernisation du
matériel et du réseau comme vous l'avez
rappelé je tiens à souligner enfin que
ces investissements prioritaires qui
seront déclinés dans le cadre des
contrats de projets état région ne met
pas loin de là la question que vous
soulevez vous avez raison de le faire du
des croisements des flux sur le rer c
entre paris et juvisy question qui est
de fait intégrer dans le cadre du schéma
directeur du rer c je leur dis devant
vous et ni celle du goulot
d'étranglement que constitue le tunnel
châtelet gare du nord pour les rer b et
d
la mise à l'étude de son dédoublement
est d'ailleurs inscrite au protocole
d'accord état région enfin tous ces
projets vient s'ajouter le prolongement
d'eole à l'ouest qui contribuera à la
cohérence du réseau et au maillage fin
du rer avec le grand paris express
si pour la réplique monsieur bétail wima
président j'aurais remercier monsieur le
ministre de sa réponse d'autant que ce
qu'il m'a dit sur le plateau de saclay
maucourt me convient bien on est dans
l'attenté j'espère que bon le calendrier
n'a pas été respectée mais j'espère que
effectivement la non ce qui fait
aujourd'hui pour l'automne sera tenu
nous y sommes extrêmement sensibles pour
le reste sur les rer je me comprends
bien que c'est un sujet qui nous tient
un petit peu au tri par les habitants
des communes de l'essonne sont
confrontés tous les jours à ce problème
et ils sont confrontés aussi depuis des
années à des effets d'annoncé sans que
ça suive
alors c'est vrai que 500 millions c'est
pas négligeable c'est un nouveau signal
j'espère simplement que derrière la
région va mettre l'équivalent comme elle
se le doit et que ces sommes seront
réellement dépensées parce qu'on a
vraiment besoin et au delà effectivement
le problème du des croisements et le
problème du tunnel qui reste encore à
financer
il a parlé maintenant madame dominique
voynet pour le groupe socialiste
mais si malin présidente le seul
ministre grand paris de quoi parle-t-on
au juste du réseau
en pari de la société du grand paris de
ce nouvel ensemble né de cet accord qui
s'est nouée entre la région et l'état
dans le creuset du débat public et dont
le nom de code est aujourd'hui grand
paris express de façon encore provisoire
des projets de territoire grand paris
paris métropole ile de france
évidemment il faut discuter tout cela le
sdrif adopté en 1994 est à la fois
techniquement obsolètes et politiquement
caduc le sdrif adopté en septembre 2008
n'a pas eu l'heur de plaire à l'état
après deux ans de dissension le
gouvernement et la région ont
semble-t-il trouvé un compromis et vous
avez transmis au conseil d'état un
projet de décret portant approbation du
sdrif en juin 2010 en octobre de la même
année
celui ci aurait rendu un avis négatif au
motif notamment que le sdrif ne prendrai
pas correctement en compte ni les deux
lois grenelle de l'environnement adopté
respectivement en 2009 et 2010 ni la loi
sur le réseau de transports alors
baptisé grand paris
et pour cause le sdrif de 94 n'est pas
non plus compatibles avec ses lois
depuis on attend on attend à nouveau
sdrif pour valider les documents
d'urbanisme des collectivités plans
locaux d'urbanisme ou schéma de
cohérence territoriale au cours de ces
derniers mois les discussions ont été
engagées avec le conseil régional vous
avez promis effectivement de libérer les
projets des collectivités
dans cette optique sera étudiée demain
l'excellente proposition de loi de
nicole bru dix ans à trouver une
solution transitoire
je suis sûr que vous saurez trouver
demain une solution intelligente pour
éviter que ne coexistent des situations
très hétéroclite des communes pourraient
avoir des documents d'urbanisme
compatible avec le sdrif 94 d'autres des
documents d'urbanisme révisé sur la base
du prix de 94 d'autres encore des
documents d'urbanisme élaboré sur la
base du stress de 2008
en fait il ne peut y avoir 15 drif est
pas inscrit à la carte
inventer une procédure dérogatoire pour
sortir du blocage pourquoi pas mais
qu'elle est réellement la porte de
sortie
telle est la question que je vous pose
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
ministre marc le ministre
la ville monsieur leroy merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre dominique
voynet je vous remercie de votre
question elle finalement ouvre le débat
que nous allons avoir demain et vous
comprendrez que non pas je ne veuille
pas vous répondre sur le fond mais je
peux pas le faire là en deux minutes
alors qu'on va voir demain une
discussion générale des amendements le
rapport et voilà donc nous reviendrons
sur le débat simplement en quelques mots
dans dans le temps qui m'est donnée oui
le sdrif est bloqué parce que comme vous
le savez vous l'avez très bien dit
d'ailleurs est une décision du conseil
d'état qui l'a rejetée et qui s'impose
non seulement au gouvernement comme à la
région
voilà et la proposition de loi si me
réponse juste vous intéresse
sinon je peux faire plus court séjour
page jeune et si si la proposition de
loi que nous adoptons demain devant
votre haute assemblée est effectivement
adopté je le souhaite vraiment parce que
c'est le moyen de débloquer l'ensemble
des projets et je me réjouis
vous avez dit que c'est une bonne
proposition de loi c'est vrai je veux
saluer le travail de madame briques je
le ferai demain et des groupes
socialistes c'est effectivement un bon
texte qui va permettre de respecter
l'accord que j'ai conclu le 26 janvier
que le président huchon puisque dans cet
accord
j'avais dit effectivement que l'état
s'engager à débloquer le sdrif mais
comme vous le savez madame voynet y
compris la proposition de loi je très
concret à la question vous avez posé y
compris la proposition de loi que nous
allons adopter
elle a le mérite d'exister elle va
permettre de débloquer les projets mais
elle n'est de vertus que transitoire je
les dis d'ailleurs il vous étiez présent
je vous en remercie devant la commission
des affaires économiques que transitoire
et ça signifie et donc vous aurez
satisfaction par rapport à votre
questionnement qui est tout à fait
légitime
ça signifie que nous allons
devoir retravailler et j'étais très
sensible à deux choses que vous avez
évoqué de façon importante devant la
commission vous êtes réjouit du débat
public
et vous avez raison de le faire ce débat
public a été formidable sur le terrain
partout plus de 20000 franciliens des
dizaines de cahiers d'acteurs et ça a
permis effectivement ça et vous avez dit
il faut pas que tout ce travail qui a
été fait soit perdu vous avez raison il
ne sera pas perdu et nous allons grâce à
la proposition de loin de madame briques
faire en sorte que ce travail
enrichissent le futur schéma régional
d'ile-de-france dans la tente on a
vraiment besoin de ce dispositif
transitoire pour libérer les projets
merci pour la réplique mal à moynat une
minute
merci madame la présidente avec une
remarque et une prolongation de la
discussion
une remarque le conseil d'état n'a pas
rendu une décision mais un simple avis
consultatif qui ne s'impose pas au
gouvernement une volonté de prolonger la
discussion
le gouvernement a décidément un problème
de gestion du temps il eût pu sur la
tête davantage pour permettre l'adoption
définitive du sdrif de 2008 et prendre
quelques mois de plus pour construire un
consensus plus solide sur les tracés du
projet de réseau de transport qu'ils
nous proposent ainsi pour la desserte du
plateau de saclay où le débat reste vif
la question de savoir si on peut se
contenter d'un bus à haut niveau de
service s'il faut un tramway métro
automatique léger ou encore un métro
souterrain beaucoup plus coûteux mais je
voudrais aussi évoqué le tracé de la
double boucle à l'est nous sommes mis
d'accord sur l'obligation desservir
correctement clichy montfermeil où
descartes par la boucle distale en
revanche pour ce qui concerne la boucle
proximale on est très loin d'un
consensus
si aucune proposition des fêtes pour
desservir val-de-fontenay correctement
je pense qu'on va au delà de grandes
difficultés
et puis je voudrais qu'on puisse revenir
dans le détail
sur des décisions qui ont été prises de
façon trop hâtive décidément je pense
notamment aux ambiguïtés aux
insuffisances pointé par le stif lors de
son dernier conseil d'administration
notamment concernant la ligne 11 du
métro il y aurait peut-être d'autres
propositions
affiné donnons-nous quelques semaines ou
quelques mois de plus pour aller au bout
de ce débat sur les tracés si la parole
et d'un monsieur christian cambon pour
le groupe de l'union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre face à l'engorgement quotidien
des voiries et des transports en commun
à l'est de l'agglomération parisienne le
val-de-marne et l'ensemble des
collectivités ont été les premiers à
mettre en évidence la nécessité absolue
de disposer d'une double boucle à
travers le projet de métro automatique
orbival il s'agissait et il s'agit
toujours bien évidemment de fluidifier
les échanges par une liaison en rocade
de banlieue à banlieue de grandes
capacités avec une desserte cadencée du
territoire ce projet vous le savez
monsieur le ministre a fait l'objet
d'études techniques approfondies qui ont
confirmé la faisabilité viabilité
économique
mais plus encore les faits majeurs de
développement qu'il peut susciter sur
les territoires qu'ils traversent ce
projet orbival a du reste était le
précurseur du projet du grand paris
express
ce projet maintenant à l'étude or
actuellement deux possibilités de tracés
sont proposés par vos collaborateurs
le passage du grand paris express par
noisy monde est et neuilly-sur-marne
tracé proposé par le conseil général de
seine-saint-denis qui se fonde sur des
statistiques anciennes et
d'hypothétiques perspectives de
développement ou bien le passage par val
de fontenay et jean ping qui eux
disposent d'ores et déjà deux pôles
économiques et donc de milliers
d'emplois existants il est évident que
ce dernier trace est le seul qui puisse
donner satisfaction aux populations et
aux territoires concernés car il
apportera une solution efficace et
immédiate à la 6e' des réseaux dans
cette partie de la région
c'est donc un choix décisif que vous
allez faire
l'est et ce choix doit donc s'appuyer
sur des critères objectifs et
irréfutables faute de quoi le débat
public sur le grand projet du grand
paris n'aurait pas servi à grand chose
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
souhaite connaître votre position
quant à la nécessité de faire réaliser
des études actualisée du trafic et de la
cartographie économique de l'est
parisien et ce afin que ce choix se
fasse sur des chiffres de trafic fiable
et actuel et prennent en compte
l'attractivité de ces pôles installé
dans le val de marne
merci monsieur maurice leroy ministre de
la ville
voilà en charge du grand paris madame la
présidente bien monsieur le sénateur
christian cambon vous avez raison de
souligner le rôle moteur et précurseur
cajou et l'association orbival et son
projet de métro automatique de rocade
dans le val de marne
vous évoquez également la question de la
desserte de val de fontenay et
illustrait bien ainsi les enjeux de bien
utiliser les infrastructures existantes
et de bien desservir les pôles de
développement actuels et à venir
à cet égard le 1er eux qui assurent avec
le erreur à et à terme avec le t1
comme vous le savez une excellente
desserte de val de fontenay a encore
beaucoup de marge de croissance et son
cadencement pourra être renforcée donc
je tiens à vous rassurer sur ce point la
tangentielle nord pourrait également
être prolongé en une tangentielle ouest
et voilà qui vous donnerait satisfaction
qui pourrait à l'horizon de la
réalisation de l'interconnexion sud des
tgv rallier orly par la grande ceinture
vous évoquez également les options de
liaison métro automatique entre le val
de marne et la seine saint denis ce
projet extrêmement complexe inscrit au
protocole d'accord etat-région du 26
janvier sous contraintes budgétaires je
rappelle devant
le ministre jean-pierre fourcade 2
milliards euros d'euros fait
actuellement l'objet à ma demande d'une
expertise conjointe de la datar et de la
société du grand paris pour bien caler
les hypothèses de trafic vous l'évoquiez
et les potentiels de développement sur
lesquels s'appuiera la décision finale
je tiens à le dire devant vous très
clairement j'ai demandé effectivement
qu'on fasse expertiser etc ont
effectivement des études qu'ils puissent
bien nous éclairer avant la décision
finale et je veux le dire très
clairement devant la haute assemblée
je pense que nous avons besoin et c'est
ce que j'ai demandé à la data de
travailler à un projet commun saintes
saint denis val de marne
il doit pas y avoir d'opposition entre
la seine saint denis et le val demain et
on doit pouvoir conjuguer effectivement
les efforts parce que voilà on doit
pouvoir travailler ensemble
seine-saint-denis val-de-marne
le rapport d expertise me sera rendu
dans le courant du mois d'avril pour
pouvoir être pris en compte dans le
schéma d'ensemble que présentera donc la
société du grand paris en mai donc voilà
monsieur comment je pense sincèrement
que vous pouvez être assurés papa mes
déclarations
mais parce que c'est un engagement clair
et si j'ai confié une mission
d'expertisé d'études et pour rapprocher
les points de vue entre le val-de-marne
et la seine-saint-denis c'est pour
qu'effectivement nous puissions vraiment
travailler un bon projet commun de
desserte qui ne laisse tomber ni le val
de marne ni la seine-saint-denis voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire milite pour
la répliquer mais merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie
des clarifications que vous venez
d'apporter car il y avait effectivement
un certain nombre d'informations qui
pouvait nous laisser penser qu'un choix
avait déjà été fait vous venez de
confirmer ici devant la haute assemblée
qu'il savait qu'il s'agira de valider à
travers des études sérieuses les
expertises qui sont actuellement en
cours
il ne s'agit bien évidemment pas de
m la senza ni de côté je le dis
sympathiquement à mon collègue jack
mahias avec lequel nous travaillons dans
un autre grand pari celui de l'eau il
s'agit simplement de prendre en compte
la souffrance des gens qui travaillent
dans l'est de paris et singulièrement
dans le bal demain je rappelle que la
ligne a du rer c 1 million de voyageurs
qui sont véhiculées dans des conditions
invraisemblables de difficultés ce sont
270 mille véhicules jour sur l'autoroute
a4 et j'espère effectivement comme vous
venez de le dire que les deux
départements et donc le val de marne
trouvera un avantage concret à la
réalisation de ce projet merci monsieur
le ministre
merci dernier intervenant monsieur
philippe dominati pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le ministre ce débat démontre
que l'impulsion donnée par le président
de la république quelques mois après son
élection suscite l'intérêt parce que
effectivement elle est nécessaire pour
une vision je dirais quotidienne mais
également économique et internationale
de notre région et ce débat va bien
au-delà des limites de la région ile de
france
pour autant les mécanismes employés
puisque cette loi est la première étape
de cette vision
le mécanisme employés pour
l'organisation des transports et l'a
quelque peu une vision conservatrice
en réalité vous avez répondu tout à
l'heure à monsieur verra qui n'avaient
pas de vision libérale je vous en donne
tout à fait acte puisque nous sommes la
seule région de france voire même la
seule du monde à conserver un monopole
public pour les transports collectifs
contrairement à tous des villes montrent
que nous voulons concurrencer dans la
vision du grand paris
et tout cela à un coût évidemment et ce
coût 32 milliards il va peser par des
impôts nouveaux
un impôt spécifique sur les parisiens et
sur les franciliens de versement
transport et sur les entreprises et sur
l'emploi
alors pour ce coup pour cette dynamique
pour cette nécessité
je suppose que le gouvernement a choisi
cette option d'une part pour des raisons
de paix sociale et d'autre part de
rapidité rapidité dans l'exécution du
projet
alors la nécessité par rapport au coût
qui est quand même particulièrement
onéreux parce que des sociétés d'état
nous avons eu la sncf ratp
la réseau ferré de france et si les
trois premières sociétés d'état ne
fonctionne pas pourquoi en créer une
quatrième
alors la question qui peut être posée
c'est une parcelle qui a été évoqué
quelques instants auparavant par mon
collègue béteille celle axe central
puisque la régie de projet fonctionnera
et s'il fonctionne il faut renforcer
l'axé central et la mise en études ne
suffit pas deuxièmement c'est une
incohérence technique
c'est pourquoi yat-il rupture de charge
entre le centre de l'agglomération et
roissy charles de gaulle et surtout que
se passe-t-il si comme d'habitude
l'état fait des dépassements financiers
qui paiera le surcoût dit monsieur leroi
moore ministre de la ville merci madame
la présidente monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati
effectivement vous vous resituer bien
l'enjeu est effectivement du grand paris
et je fus en quelque sorte vous rassurer
si j'ai bien compris
allons-y carrément et parlons
franchement est clair c'est encore mieux
votre inquiétude c'est plutôt la société
du grand paris serait fait d'inférence
avec la sncf non mais par pudeur ce que
je comprends et je vous en remercie vous
n'avez pas évoqué mais je préfère qu'on
mettre carrément les pieds dans le plat
et qu'on l'évoquent franchement voilà la
société du grand paris qui est issu de
la loi du 3 juin 2010 par définition ça
devrait faire plaisir à madame voynet
c'est un établissement public
biodégradables puisque sa mission s'est
réalisé le métro automatique la rocade
du métro automatique les 150 km de métro
automatique de portée l'emprunt est
ensuite effectivement et bien
c'est l'exploitation qui sera remise
d'où le questionnement légitime d'un de
madame la ministre catherine tasca tout
à l'heure sur qu'est ce qu'il adviendra
quand on remettra à l'exploitation
syndicat des transports d'ile-de-france
est normal que nous ayons ces
discussions et c'est normal qu'elle soit
serré je suis je n'oublie pas que je
suis élu moi-même et et à la place du
stif je me poserai les mêmes questions
dans quelles conditions on va remettre
sur le financement
franchement c'est vous qui en avaient la
maîtrise monsieur le sénateur dominati
et moi je fais confiance aussi bien la
haute assemblée qu'au sénat pour veiller
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas les dérapages
mais demandez aux mines jean pierre
fourcade qui a été le rapporteur du
texte qui suit et qui veillent toujours
attentivement à cela à ces travaux nous
avons effectivement tous les moyens de
réaliser cela sans dérapage
et d'ailleurs si j'ai tenu bon parce que
c'est une question intéressante votre
interpellation
vous me dites attention et je l'entends
aux dérapages parce que où on va aller
dans les financements puis c'est curieux
mais dès qu'on quitte l'hémicycle
je suis quelqu'un vous seul qui parle
clair qu'ils aiment bien parler franc
c'est comme ça comme des états les ans
si toute vérité n'est pas bonne à dire
les toujours bonnes à entendre et bien
mais c'est curieux et sur le terrain
partout où je me déplace on me demande
des gares supplémentaires dont il faut
aussi savoir ce que l'on veut et
justement si je tiens bon et fermement
ça devrait plutôt vous rassurer c'est
pour éviter justement ces dérapages
rappelle pour mémoire que une gare comme
ça un au hasard
c'est au minimum 80 millions d'euros
donc je le dis attention parce que il
faut qu'on ait le même discours dans
l'hémicycle de la haute assemblée de
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi sur le
terrain parce qu'on veut pas dire ici
attention la dérive des finances
publiques
et quand on redevient un élu local dire
je veux absolument maga donc moi je ne
vous ne pouvez que m'aider dans la
mission que m'a confiée le président de
la république et le premier ministre à
faire attention effectivement aussi à
maintenir ce grand paris qui encore une
fois est un magnifique projet pour
l'international aussi pour le
rayonnement international
les clés l'ensemble des capitales parle
de ce projet je sais pas si on ne mesure
nous même si on a toujours bien
conscience c'est aussi l'éclat de nos
architectes français qui ont un
rayonnement aussi international et qui
convient de saluer voilà j'espère vous
avoir complètement assuré monsieur le
sénateur monsieur dominati une minute
pour la réplique
monsieur le ministre vous m'avez
partiellement rassurés parce que je
pense que votre mission peut être
effectivement une mission absolument
nécessaire et que vous accomplissez avec
beaucoup d'habileté
mais dans le moyen terme parce qu'une
évolution institutionnelle est
absolument nécessaire et pour les
sociétés de transport puisque aucune des
villes monde dont vous parlez ne prend
ce mécanisme aucune parce qu'il est trop
onéreux il coûte cher
et effectivement nous avons le même
souci commun de la dépense publique
deuxièmement il ya le problème du
périmètre j'entendais de mes collègues
de seine-maritime parler par exemple de
la nécessité ils ont raison et vous nous
invitez mais la taxe spéciale
d'équipement est ce qu'elle va aller
jusqu'en seine maritime par exemple
parce que pour l'instant elle concerne
les parisiens c'est une question que je
poserai très prochainement dans le débat
budgétaire il faut savoir quelle est la
vision exacte du grand paris donc vous
m'avez donné une réponse qui dans la
nécessité du court terme peux me
satisfaire
mais en réalité l'évolution est plus que
nécessaire parce qu'elle sera
contemporaine merci mes chers collègues
j'ai le très gros plaisir au nom du
sénat tout entier
vivre en direct sur notre antenne les
questions cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui au grand paris le grand
paris ce n'est pas seulement la sphère
des parisiens et des franciliens a
martelé en séance maurice leroy le
ministre de la ville il a répondu aux
questions des sénateurs concernant
notamment le rôle du stif le syndicat
des transports en ile de france
il a rassuré catherine tasca estimant
que le rôle donc ne sera pas du stif ne
sera pas remise en cause le prolongement
de la ligne 14 entre saint-ouen et saint
lazare sera bien confié au stif
en vertu de l'accord signé entre l'état
et la région ile de france
en ce qui concerne le plateau de saclay
dont il a été beaucoup question cette
après midi lors de cette séance de
questions cribles maurice leroy a
également répondu aux inquiétudes des
sénateurs concernant la préservation des
espaces agricoles mais aussi sur le
déménagement des universités parisiennes
à saclay il ne se fera pas au détriment
des universités parisiennes intra muros
a promis maurice leroy le ministre de la
ville
enfin il a également été beaucoup
question d'une proposition de loi de la
sénatrice socialiste nicole bricq qui
sera débattue demain en séance et qui
propose de modifier plusieurs
dispositions du code de l'urbanisme pour
débloquer certains chantiers en
ile-de-france chantiers bloqués par le
projet de loi du grand paris
voilà donc pour cette séance de
questions cribles merci de votre
fidélité prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
c'est à 19h avec michel grossiord bonne
soirée à tous sur public sénat